voici un sac à champignon et sa version
miniature la boîte à champignon fini les
heures passées le dos courbé en forêt à
chercher des pleurottes celles-ci
viennent à vous à l'origine de ce
produit original une start-up evelinoise
née en 2011 donc en fait c'est ni plus
ni moins que les sacs que vous voyez là
mais miniaturisé pour que ça aille dans
votre cuisine donc en fait c'est une
petite boîte que vous ouvrez vous
l'arrosez et 15 jours plus tard dans
votre cuisine vous avez C pleot et le
succès est au rendez-vous la startup
devrait connaître 100 % cette année et
atteindre un chiffre d'affaires de
600000 € mais n'a pas inventé ce concept
d'agriculture urbaine provenant de
l'hémisphère sud depuis très longtemps
dans les pays en voie de développement
on cherche à transformer des résidus de
culture en champignon pour améliorer les
les les enjeux notamment nutritionnels
locaux l'idée qui a qui qu'on a eu à la
boîte à champignon c'est de c'est
d'appliquer ce système qui existe au
Mexique ou au Bostwana par exemple en
Afrique à la région île-de-fance ici les
conditions d'humidité d'un sous-bois en
automne ont été recréés dans un espace
de 600 m² on fait même croire aux
champignons que des sangliers rôent à
proximité quand on appuie comme ça sur
les sacs c'est ce qu'on appelle du
stress mécanique c'est-à-dire que dans
la forêt parfois vous avez des animaux
comme les sangliers par exemple qui
fouille un peu le sol et ça ça stimule
la la croissance des champignons et donc
sur les sacs comme ça où on n pas tout à
fait assez de grappe et ben on va les
stimuler en les massant quoi en fait le
procédé donne une pleurotte de qualité
tenant bien la cuisson celle-ci a été
distinguée par le collège culinaire de
France et plusieurs chefs étoilés en
raffol on a un produit qui ne va pas
rendre d'eau à la cuisson d'accord
contrairement à la grande majorité des
champignons et donc qui va rester
croquant quand qu vous allez le goûter
avec une vraie texture et ça les chef
ador inscrite dans une démarche
écologique et solidaire la start-up
vient de lever 500000 € de l'argent
frais qui lui permettra de doubler sa
capacité de production et de lancer
d'autres champignonnières comme celle-ci
ailleurs en France